ηά μια παρίδον βασικά γίνετον το πρόβλινα σε μια περίοδον που περιμένουμε των τουρισμόκριά να
ώρα θεωρώ ότι πρέπει όλοι μας να θυνεις φέρουμε και πρέπει όλημα να βάλουμε το
λυθαράκι μας με τον τρόμο τον δικό μακι επειδή στην λάρ να κάνε νι φαλά
τοσ οη κεντρική διπλάαπό τα οροτρόμιο που κάλει πολλές ποσότητες οι με το αναγκυκλόμενο νερό
οι μέρεις ενέργες που έγιναν και ιναν ποστές ενέργειες τα τελευταία χρόνια και από την
δαδο προμήθεια οθερωίτ είπε ξε κάθειστέριηλπάνωσε αυτόν το θέμα στα χώρα περιμέναμε να να στάξουν
να το πομεεγια νκατηγορώγια να πω τώρα ότι κάννοκριτική αλλά το γυός ότι ηβουρούσαμε να
ποιαμε νκινητές ανδλίες πριν το καλοκύρι ντάξε τούτο δείχνε ότι εμπορούσε να είναι νας καλύπτρος
προγραμμαρισμός ποι σνε τον πιρούν το πράγμα στμε ία υπελλάδες ενκαικαι θέλω από ότι ντα
από τελετήσμάτα που διεχρουν κάτι νκαι ήτα που καλόκι τα πουλαλς ενώ μνεβορούσαμε τώρα να
βρουμε λύσεις κινητών αντριών το μάι αντιλαβάννε τ ότι κάτι επίχινα κάτι πιχει κλίνοντας μεγαλύτερο
στόχο στο αντριάβυρα πριν να φύγει να τεγι να να πει το νερό στα υλάκι
με τγια το λιμάνι κι τη μαρίνα μκ ως είναινα έρτουν τα πανεπιστή μια τα
οποία στο χέουμε κατιυπουήσιματικό είναι να ξεκινήσειισωστεί αναψηξή στην προχή τω δεξαμνω του λμανιού και
της μαρίνας και ναι να τροχειορομηθεί όι στα χάρτια όι ευρέθει κρεμετήρι και αν το
κάμι τοζήσαμε τονα πει χύρος μέσι το λιμάνι και στη α του τα ύθερα χρόνια
και να τελοιώσον και μιας ανα πουκέρκα πυ έχουμε εξεκίνημε αλλά πούντατρία νομίζω τ στημαντικό
για τομάια ίμάρχειμε φαιστόπαρα πολίε συζήσει επο καλά τώρα σε καλά φιλές και φίλι άλλο
έναντε ένα λά ερότ κάσε εφτάσει στο τέλος το ταλέ με την ερχομενα επδωμάτα